when you let go of the past your pastor
will let go of
you the reason why i encourage people to
get out of that mindset
is because that's just a one-way ticket
to a lifelong
commitment to sadness disappointment
lethargy complacency and feeling stuck
and lost don't miss an
opportunity to tell someone how much
they mean to you
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
jay shetty and my take on his top 10
rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one adopt the 3s
model the first thing i'd say is i think
everyone needs
the feeling that they can just come up
for some air
life can often feel like someone's
literally
drowning you and you feel like you're
drowning and floundering especially
if you're in an extreme case of anxiety
or stress or depression
and i feel like you just need to feel
like you can just come up for a tiny bit
of air
so for that in the book i talk about the
3s model which is your sights
sense and sounds what we see
what we hear and what we smell has a
profound
impact on our mental state and we
actually underestimate our sense and
i'll give you an example all of us been
walking around with masks and someone
said this to me the other day and it hit
me
they were saying to me that now that we
all were mosque and do this the whole
time i think my mom's over there
they were doing this all the time they
realized they couldn't hear people
properly
and the reason they can hear people
properly is they realize they don't use
their ears they use their eyes
to see people's lips and so actually
they're not even using their ears that
much they're using their eyes
to follow the lips and know what
someone's saying
so actually we depend so much on our
eyes
in every interaction how many times i've
been looking at someone attractive and
you forgot what they were talking about
right you're just so engaged with your
eyes that you completely even forgot to
listen
right or you're so lost in in the vision
of something again and you're in a daze
you can't smell anything you can't taste
anything so
we've got to learn to reactivate our
senses so i'll give an example of what i
mean
as monks our life was sight
designed sound designed and scent
designed what's the first thing you see
when you wake up in the morning
for eighty percent of people the first
thing they see in the morning is their
phone
and the last thing they see at night is
their phone that is
poor sight design because you don't even
choose what the first message of the day
your mind receives that
actually made my stomach drop that's a
gnarly thought
it's true yeah right imagine the last
thing someone sees is not their partner
or their spouse
the person they sleep with they see
their phone and the first thing in the
morning they look at is their phone
and guess what it's not a good site
because you're looking at a message that
you didn't design for your mind
you're looking at a picture or an image
that maybe came through on your
instagram feed
that you didn't choose for your mind so
now you've started your jay with envy
jealousy comparison competition collab
like all of the all of the monkey mind
stuff and the monkey mind's excited the
monkey mine's on
the monkey mind's like yeah we're ready
to go and now you started the day with
the monkey mind
so my advice is start your day with a
quote that you love
start your day with a picture of someone
that you love or your family
start your day with a work of art that
inspires you start your day
with seeing the first thing that you see
make it so closely connected to your
soul and your goal and your purpose
that your monk mind naturally comes
alive
so as monks the first thing that we saw
was sometimes a teaching that we'd keep
next to us it might be a spiritual text
where i just ripped it out of a book
and stuck it there next to my bed so i
woke up to that
just wake up to something that you
actually want to see when you wake up
and make it intentional make it focus it
could even be a reminder on a sticky
note
i remember for a long time i had one
when i was a monk that said i am not
this body
just to disconnect from the fact that i
was more than this body
and because we didn't have mirrors in
the ashram it was very easy to forget i
was this body
or i've had other ones where that say to
me i'm exactly where i need to be
and i've read that in the morning and
that just reminds me because so often i
wake up feeling anxious that i'm behind
on my day or i'm late
and then i actually make up a mess
whereas if i read i'm exactly where i
need to be and i remind myself i can
start my day there
so that's sight this and that's simple
easy for anyone to do you don't have to
change your mind you don't need to
meditate you have to do anything
the second one is let's talk about scent
design
now one of the things i've been missing
during quarantine is going to a spa
or going to like a resort because i love
massages and i love spas and like me and
my wife love getting away
and if you think about it whenever you
go into a spa
or a massage space or whatever they're
called or a resort
you can always feel relaxed from the
moment you walk in just through the
power of
scent it could be the most basic room in
the world
but a scent can literally illuminate a
whole room
so since like eucalyptus lavender
sandalwood
if you've got a diffuser or a candle and
you can make this a part of your routine
before you start your work day just have
a candle that you breathe in for four
seconds and breathe out for four seconds
have a diffuser in your room that just
makes you feel calm because as soon as
you walk in
one thing i've been doing is putting
eucalyptus drops into my showers
and turning into a natural steam and i
just feel like completely relieving all
my sinuses and
and feeling calm these are just really
practical things you can do to just
ease yourself into it and the third one
sound this one's so
powerful sound is underestimated because
now we just have music playing all the
time in the background and the music may
not even be intentional and the lyrics
are all over the place and
you've got instruments that are not
being played well or in harmony and
you get a pump or like a boost out of it
and i learned about sound in the ashram
and we had sound design we would wake up
to nature sounds
and nature's so aligned with your body
and mind if you look at
nature if you breathe in with the ocean
your breath will just be exactly where
it needs to be
if you allow yourself to just be present
with the wind you'll feel your body just
slow right down and be calm nature just
has this
amazing way of teaching so many lessons
and so when i lived in new york city i
often found myself getting exhausted and
i started looking into it i was thinking
what is it i work out i do all this
stuff
and i realized that especially in new
york we deal with a lot of
insignificant sound you know something
called cognitive load where your brain
is processing irrelevant in significant
sound of
trucks horns construction work and
drilling
and so when your ears are trying to make
sense of insignificant sound
you're losing energy in an irrelevant
way
and so sound design means every room in
your home
have a song that plays or music that
plays in that room that gives you the
feeling you want it to have
another easy way to do that is before
you start work or while you're working
have a song or a playlist that really
gets you into the mode that you want to
be in when you're doing that
sound is a beautiful accomplice to any
activity you want
so those are three simple ways that
anyone starting today
can bring the ashram to their home
by sight scent and sound design because
that's how our lives were designed
rule number two start living in the now
when you let go of the past your pastor
will let go of
you and that's harder to do like it's
easy to say it's hard to do
the way to stop living in the past is
start living in the now so start making
plans right now start making plans for
the future start spending time with
people who also don't get nostalgic i
remember
at one point in my life i got a detached
from a lot of people who spent a lot of
time in the past now
they weren't negative people they always
talked about how things used to be great
in the old days you know nostalgia that
oh it felt so good a few years ago that
was the best years of my life i started
to disconnect from that
because i realized that i didn't want to
be living feeling like
the best years of my life were going to
be at university and end there
the best years of my life for as a
teenager and end there i always want
every year to be the best year of my
life right i never wanted to settle
or limit myself for the feeling that the
best years of my life have already
passed
so sometimes it's not even negativity
it's just not allowing us to move
forward rule number three express love
don't miss an opportunity to tell
someone
how much they mean to you i just don't
and i said it better than that somewhere
i can't find it right now but
i i mean that like just don't miss an
opportunity like i was saying that with
my mentor i always told him i loved him
always and now that i can't tell him
anymore i'm just glad i did tell him
it's like yeah totally so like don't
ever
leave someone with about don't ever
leave someone without telling them
how much they mean to you because you
don't know when they'll leave
oh and and so like that is just like
never let your last interaction with
someone you know you're a bad woman or a
bad one yeah
yeah express love or just generosity
exactly especially the people you love
right like you may have bad interactions
with people you
once or twice or a business but the
people that are close to you and you
love the people you'll regret it with
don't just don't it's just
not worth living with rule number four
live your purpose
i encourage so many people that i coach
so many people i mentor
obviously everyone in my community and
audience and everything
to go and follow that go and live that
purpose
and i see time and time again that when
i see people
trying to live their purpose they are
protected that it
things work when you're playing in your
dharma and your purpose things
work things move you feel momentum they
happen
and i'm not saying they happen without
effort but they happen they move whereas
when you're not you just constantly feel
like you're grinding up against
you know a war i know challenges just
just constant
so what is your purpose and when did you
discover it
good question what is my purpose is
simple it always has been since
not since the beginning because i
discovered it afterwards my purpose is
making wisdom
go viral and i've stuck with that i've
kept it that way because
to me and there's more to it making
wisdom go viral through entertainment i
would say is my purpose
because i believe that that is something
that is uniquely
my goal impact and service
and the beautiful thing is i'm not
limited to a platform so that could be
books it can be podcasts it can be tv
shows it can be moved
it's not limited and this i learned by
reading i was reading after and this was
after my video started to
to get seen this wasn't before i did it
it wasn't like i sat down and i wrote
this fancy tagline
i was reading saleem ishmael's book
called exponential organizations
and in this book he talks about
something called an mtp
a massive transformational purpose and
he says that
every major person organization in the
world has an
mtp so an mtp has to be aspirational
it has to be massive and it has to be
service and purpose based
so google's is organizing the world's
information
notice it doesn't say we're an seo
company notice it doesn't say
we do google ads they're organizing the
world's
information that's how big they're
dreaming
and when you're organizing the world's
information you can do driverless cars
you can do google glass
you can sell google ads whatever it is
and so ted's is ideas worth spreading
that's what they are that's what about
so jay shetty is making wisdom go viral
that's what i'm dedicated to
everyone i have been reading a bit from
my friend's book evan carmichael built
to serve and i wanted to share this with
you
so according to a study by carnegie
mellon university
people with supportive spouses are more
likely to give themselves
the chance to succeed they studied 163
married couples
and found that people with supportive
spouses were more likely
to take on potentially rewarding
challenges
those who accepted challenges experience
more personal growth
happiness and psychological well-being
now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife i was
just starting out i had never released a
video i hadn't created any content
and she was such an important part of
feeling supported on that journey so
whether you're in a relationship whether
you're dating whether you're married or
even if you're single
being supported by friends and a strong
community is important
uh build to serve by evan carmichael
great book
on how you can find your purpose and
also on reminding us
that we can all make a difference in the
world thanks evan rule number five
accept the pain and often people try and
belittle and devalue their own pain to
get out of it
but that actually just slows down the
process and then they're back to square
one again
so you've got to accept the pain you
went through you've got to accept that
you want to heal it
one of the best ways to explain this is
how what we search for in our partners
or in life
is what we did or didn't get from our
parents
that's interesting like literally what
we search for and i've i've analyzed
this in my life a ton and
others if you look for what you look for
in your partner
or for what you look for in life through
your bosses any authorities
anyone who has a position of power in
your life is what you didn't
or did get from your parents and so
you're creating a life
based on your past trauma or your past
challenge
that doesn't lead to a positive
relationship i found myself projecting
the patterns the negative patterns
that my parents had into my relationship
with my wife
that doesn't create a positive
experience and by the way i'm not
blaming any parents in the world
everyone's figuring it out so i'm not
even blaming my own but
we need to have the awareness of
developing the emotional skills that our
parents didn't have
so again reminding ourselves of being
aware
that we're literally creating lives that
will continue in the same direction
unless our mindset changes
rule number six overcome envy when you
feel wendy when you feel jealousy you've
got
three responses three kind of wired
responses in the way you behave there
are more there's multifaceted layers
but let's start with three the lowest
form is ignorance
you want to complain you want to compare
you want to criticize
you want to wish like you have it that's
the lowest form of response that's where
we start
and that's okay and therefore the first
point is just recognizing that that's
where we start
a layer up from that an improvement from
that is okay that person's going out
then getting it i'm not just going to
mope about the fact that they've got
stuff i want i'm going to work and i'm
going to show them i'm going to compete
with them
well i'm going to work as hard as they
are and see how it gets but you're still
comparing so you've given up the
criticizing aspect you've given up the
fact that over your copying
but you're still complaining you're
still comparing
higher than that is the fact that you
say actually let me care
about my needs let me praise that person
and let me become
conscious of what i actually need right
let me not complain let me not compare
let me not criticize
but let me become conscious become
self-aware of what direction is my life
going into what is it that i truly want
to achieve where is it that i really
want to go
start creating self-awareness around
those things
and naturally you start to remove envy
so you've got the ignorance
layer from that you've got the impulse
layer
and the highest you've got the
insightful layer right so you've got
ignorance impulse and insight we want to
be an
insight we want to move away from
ignorance we want to move away from
impulse you want to move
higher and higher to higher
consciousness to insight imagine
everyone in the world
operated on the level of insight right
that insight that self-conscious
awareness self-care compassion
you'd be oozing it out of yourself to
absolutely everyone around you
rule number seven get out of victim
mindset
one of the things you talk about is is
how people can begin to slide into
a victim mentality
how how do you help people around that
why
some people really do have it bad so why
do you advise them still
to not adopt the victim mentality yeah
so there's a study that i talk about in
the book that
looks at people who have a victim
mindset and by the way that is a
condition that's adopted you are not a
victim person like you're not a
negative person you just have adopted a
negative sense of thoughts and habits
and beliefs
and the study looked at people that had
those beliefs and looked to people who
didn't
and they were asked to think of a time
when they felt they were the victim
and the other people were just asked to
think of a time when they were bored
after that these two sets of people were
asked
if they'd like to take part in an
activity of just helping the team
that had created the experiment and
i think the people that were the victim
mindset were 25
less likely to offer to help and be a
part of this change
and to the degree that sometimes they
left trash behind
and even took the pens that they were
given by the experimenters to the point
that
you get so lost in that mentality that
you don't even think about helping and
getting out of it
so the reason why the victim mindset
it is real in the sense that there are
definitely people
in the world that have a harder
situation than others
that's fact there's no debating that
point that there are people who have it
are harder than other people
there are people that have hired it
harder than me but there are also people
that have it easier than me so i've had
it harder than some and same with you
and in our small bubbles our hardship
feels like the worst thing that could
ever happen
and that's the craziest thing about pain
is that you
only think pain is bad when you're
really going through it
and we compare our pain with other
people's pain we say oh that person's
pain can't be that bad
that person's pain is probably a bit
less than mine you know we
because we've never experienced it so
the reason why i encourage people to get
out of that mindset
is because that's just a one-way ticket
to a lifelong
commitment to sadness disappointment
lethargy complacency and feeling stuck
and lost
there's nothing gained out of feeling
sorry for yourself
i don't think there's anyone that i've
ever heard saying i'm open to it but
i've never heard anyone say to me
that feeling like a victim my whole life
actually helped me find a victory in
life like i don't think i've ever heard
that
i've never read that in a book i've
never heard in a documentary i've never
seen it anywhere so
if it's out there i'm open to it but
when you look at that and you go is this
the life i want to keep living do i
still want to feel this way you look at
someone like sindhutai you look at all
of these incredible people that have
broken barriers you look at people who
are told that uh wilma rudolph was told
she would never
walk again properly or run at age nine
and went went on to be a multiple
olympic gold medalist
when you hear that you're like what
really but that's what's possible
and so no one in the victim mindset has
ever
seen growth from that mindset but
everyone who has traded that victim
mindset
for a mindset of acceptance a mindset of
healing
and a mindset of perspective has found
their way out
rule number eight protect yourself being
compassionate and being
giving isn't about spending your whole
day with one person who needs your
attention and affection
if your purpose is to do something
different so for example you're putting
out this podcast
you put out video content you write
books this is serving
lots of different people in lots of ways
and you're not expecting apart from the
person buying the book
and and getting the value from you don't
really expect them to do anything for
you
right you're not asking them to come and
champion for you if they don't want to
so you're already planting those seeds
you're already sharing in that way
and i think the mistake we make is when
we are
overly compassionate to one person and
we're doing it
expecting that they're going to do
something back right
so the only way don't be overly
compassionate expecting something in
return
yeah don't just just if you see yourself
just don't do that if you're going to
feel that and that's okay
like that doesn't make you less
compassionate it doesn't make you a bad
person
like if i don't want to and i have rules
about there are certain people in my
life that i don't ask
for favors because i don't ever want to
be in a position
where i'm having to ask them because not
that they wouldn't do it or whatever i
just don't want to do that it's just not
who i am and it's like
but that's fine and there are certain
people in my life that i won't give to
because i know they're going to keep
asking for stuff and so you have to
protect yourself
and i think self-protection and being
honest with yourself
is the best way so the my favorite
analogy in this is
if someone's drowning in the ocean if
you're fit and healthy
and you're a lifeguard great you can go
and save them
but if you're not you might need to call
the real lifeguard to come and help them
out
and that's what real compassion is real
compassion if you can't help someone if
you're feeling toxic one day you're
feeling negative one day
you're feeling you're not really giving
from your heart it's better to introduce
them to someone or find someone else who
can help them
then to go in there with all these toxic
emotions and now you're expecting them
to live
on the face return the favor it's better
to not do it if you're going to do
something
and in your heart of hearts you're
actually feeling bitter and regretting
it
it's better not to do it because guess
what you weren't compassionate when you
did it with that intention
compassion is about intention it's not
about the result like
two people could give the same amount to
charity
one person gives it for pr one person
gives it because they care about the
kids
who's happy the person who gave it for
the kids the person
both people's money had the same impact
but the intention is what defined
what happened so if you're begrudgingly
going out there and helping someone and
in your half-hearts you're like oh i
can't believe they asked me
who are they like i don't even like them
like they never help me and then you
help them
that guess what that's not compassion
protect yourself deal with it deal with
that toxic emotion so
i don't help people that when i feel
like that
and i give myself that that space no
honest in the best way that you can i
don't think i can support you on this
because i don't feel right about it it
doesn't make sense to me or whatever it
is like
it's not the right fit and i think
that's actually stopping yourself from
being a people pleaser
yes because we we actually are not
compassionate we're just people pleasers
we actually just want people to think
we're like magnanimous and amazing so
we'll go and
go to every you know everything to
support everyone but it's like we're
resentful people pleasers
exactly please and then we're resentful
that we've had it exactly
and then now we want to make them feel
guilty for not doing their best so i
make a conscious effort to support the
people i love to to make an effort with
the people i love and do more there and
that's
that's fine your compassion doesn't you
don't have to be this
overarching person who's like doing it
for everyone like that's that's part of
the journey it's gonna take time to get
there rule number nine
put yourself first what is your take on
putting yourself first and like is it
selfish
so with with monk teachings the point is
you are taking care of yourself first
in order to serve better so it's always
like i'm gonna put myself
first so that i can fill up so that i
can serve with more
because we want to serve with our best
selves right i always say this people
it's like people are like jay should i
go to this party should i go out to this
event
should i call up this person should i do
this should i do that and i'm just like
well if you're going to show up there
with that energy
well you're going to have to convince
yourself to go then guess what that
person's going to feel that
right because if you want to show up and
you're going to show up with your best
so i feel
for me it's not selfish if the intention
is i want to give more and serve more
that's good it's it's selfish when it's
just like oh i'm just going to take care
of myself because that's all that
matters
right whereas it's like no i'm going to
take care of myself because i want to
give my best self to the people i love
right to the people of the world to the
people i care for and so i'm going to
keep prioritizing myself so i
went down the wrong journey when i first
started wanting to serve i used to just
think oh yeah i'm going to stay up all
night
someone needs me to drive halfway across
the country i'll do that and i would do
things like that
and i started to realize i was just
people pleasing i wasn't serving
i was actually serving my own ego that
was the most selfish thing
interesting it was the most selfish
thing because there's just people
pleasing but then i realized actually me
saying look you know what i need to get
a good night's sleep tonight
but i promise you first thing in the
morning we're going to talk about this
and i'm going to bring my best off to
this conversation
people started to respect that and value
that and gave me that space and so for
me as long as your intention is clear
that you're putting yourself first so
you can give more yeah that's the best
thing you can do because i don't want to
die early because i'm negligent of my
health right because that means you're
going to serve less in the long term
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip
is have compassion we feel so much envy
about things that other people have
that are good we don't ever feel envious
of
things that other people have that are
challenges we don't really identify that
you never look
we rarely look at people and go oh my
god i'm so lucky i don't have that
right we're more like i wish i had that
they're so lucky i wish i had that
you never look at someone who you feel
is worse off and feel oh i'm so lucky
i'm so blessed i'm so grateful i'm not
like that and then try and help them we
rarely do that so
see the mind once trained will actually
start doing that the mind will notice
gratitude
as opposed to amplifying envy
so we need to transform envy into
gratitude by actually looking around us
and thinking wow i'm actually quite
lucky
you know majority of us are richer than
90
of the planet now that sounds ridiculous
when we're all struggling to pay bills
and stuff
but in reality there are people far far
worse off and people say well i can't
relate to that
well then go there and relate to that
right i know one gentleman who i
i was speaking with and he was telling
me that when his kids were young he took
them to india
to spend time with children who had to
walk miles for water
who never had food and he made them
spend time with them gave them food gave
them water help them serve these kids
and that really taught them the value of
what they had today it's
so so important that we
train and teach children about
compassion and teach ourselves about
compassion teach adults as well if we
can't
connect to the fact that there are other
people struggling in much worse ways
then we will never really be able to
overcome our
envy now i've got a very special bonus
clip that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get motivated
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through but when you get
motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you what are
three practices for self-care that you
live by or that you give as
as examples one of my favorite ones is
what i talk about emotional vocabulary
so harvard and you can google this has
this great table
and it shows how limited our emotional
vocabulary is
so what i mean by this is if someone
asked you how's your week been
that's all right all right good bad
fine okay right how's your week going
good
how's your day been okay how are you
doing tonight
fine right that's literally how we
describe our lives sometimes i say
so good just so excited i love it good
at least you've got an expansive
emotional vocabulary it's so expensive
so expensive
but our emotional vocabulary is so
limited now there's a challenge here
we don't get to understand how we truly
feel
because we never articulate and express
it so when you say that you're angry
are you offended are you irritated are
you defensive
there's so much more to the word angry
than just anger or when you say i'm sad
when you say you're sad are you
upset are you regretful are you
triggered
right there's just so much more when you
self-diagnose and you limit your
vocabulary
you're just like oh i'm just sad i'm
just angry
and which means that you can't
articulate yourself what you're really
dealing with
and you can't articulate to a friend
what you're dealing with so you don't
feel understood
and feeling understood is such an
important part of self-care
the feeling that i can articulate what
i'm really going through
and someone understands me that's huge
for self-care i think it's one of the
most important things of self-care when
you look at someone and you feel
they really get me doesn't that isn't
that so good for your confidence and
your self-worth and your significance
you like that
correct feel loved exactly all in one
moment so for me
that's one of the best self-care
techniques is when i'm struggling with
something let me not settle for the base
level emotion
let me really understand it and then if
you're speaking to a therapist you're
speaking to your doctor you're speaking
to your friend
you can now actually articulate it
better so they can actually help you
back
[Music]
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel
just for it go check it out the link is
right there next to me
continue to believe and i'll see you
there